[موسيقى]
مرحبًا بك في ملعب الجولف الوحيد المعتمد من
قبل رابطة المحترفين في إفريقيا [موسيقى] ملعب الباوباب في vipingo ridge في
كينيا ،
وأعتقد أن الشيء المثير للاهتمام في ملعب الجولف هذا
هو أن
كل من يلعبها
يقولون جميعًا أنه لا توجد حفرة
تنسى أنها نوعًا ما  جميعهم مختلفون
ولا يُنسى جميعهم ،
إنه تحدٍ جيد ، إنه اختبار جيد
ولكنه ليس صعبًا للغاية ، إنه ممتع
جنبًا إلى جنب مع أفضل المرافق من الدرجة الأولى ، ينضم لاعبو الجولف
هنا إلى شركة غير عادية ،
إنه لأمر رائع أن تكون قادرًا على
لعب الجولف والحصول على  حصلت على حياة برية من
حولك تعرف أنها ليست خاطئة ، إنها
ليست حديقة حيوانات ، إنها فقط
المكان الذي يريدون أن يكونوا فيه ،
قد تبدو هذه الحياة البرية في المنزل
ولكنها لم تكن دائمًا بهذه الطريقة في
الأصل مزرعة السيزال حتى عام 2004
تم تحويلها منذ ذلك الحين إلى  مشروع
متعدد الاستخدامات يتألف من
ممتلكات سكنية وتجارية
جنبًا إلى جنب مع الملاذ الطبيعي ومحمية الحياة البرية
[موسيقى]
معظم الحيوانات التي تعيش هنا هي
عمليات إنقاذ ومن أجل استضافة هذه
الحيوانات ،  كان على الحكومة الكينية أن تثبت أن
لديها السعة الفضائية والغذاء
للحياة البرية
، وتشجع الحكومة الكينية على توفير
مساحة أكبر للحياة البرية ونشجع
أي شخص لديه أجزاء كبيرة من الأراضي
لتحويلها إلى محميات أو
محميات وأحدها هو
تطوير vipingo vipingo هنا الحوزة
2500 فدان وقد خصصوا 800
فدان كملاذ ولحياة
برية
[موسيقى]
لقد كان موسم الجفاف المطول هذا
العام وقد
أعطى الملعب الأولوية لري الحد الأدنى من الخضراوات للحفاظ على
المياه ومع عدم وجود الحيوانات المفترسة ، فإن
معظم الحيوانات تتمتع بحرية  نتجول
في مضغ الأشجار الأصلية المزروعة من أجل
مذاقها ،
نحاول قدر الإمكان عدم
التحكم في حركة هذه
الحيوانات والسماح لها بالتحرك بمفردها ، ولدينا
الكثير من الدفعات للسماح لها بالذهاب إلى الأدغال ،
فنحن نسمح لها فقط بإعادة توصيلها
بحيث يتلاشى هذا التفاعل البشري وأن
تكون قريبًا من الإنسان قليلاً
حيث تعمل كينيا على ترسيخ مكانتها
في عالم لعبة
غولف النخبة  تتطلع ريدج إلى الجمع بين
مستقبلها والحفظ ،
لقد أدخلنا للتو الحيوانات في
محمية بينغو هنا ،
ولكن ببطء يمكن أن تكون مركز إنقاذ
للأنواع المهددة أيضًا بالانقراض ،
على سبيل المثال ، تعتبر الحمير الوحشية المرق
مهمة لأنها معرضة للخطر في
كينيا فهي قليلة في  الأرقام لذلك
نريد تشجيع ليس فقط الحيوانات
الموجودة في كينيا ولكن حتى الحيوانات
التي يتم إحضارها إلى كينيا
والمعرضة للانقراض حاليًا في قائمتنا ،
نهدف إلى إنشاء
برنامج تربية في نهاية المطاف حيث يمكننا تربية
مخزونات
وتحسين  تجمعات الجينات بهدف
ذلك جنبًا إلى جنب مع
إعادة إدخالها إلى البرية
في المتنزهات أو إلى محميات ومناطق محمية أخرى
مثلنا
، والمضي قدمًا ، ليست ملاعب الجولف
وحدها هي التي يمكن أن تجلب الحفظ
إلى الصدارة
بشكل واضح مع الطريقة التي يتبعها السكان
يوسع الصراع البشري حول الحياة البرية
سوف يذهب في اتجاه واحد فقط ويزداد سوءًا
لذلك أعتقد أن هناك الكثير من الفرص
والنطاق  e للحكومة للشراكة مع
المطورين أصحاب الأراضي الذين لديهم أرض
يمكنهم الالتزام بها في محميات ومناطق محمية
لإنشاء مساحة
للحياة البرية
[الموسيقى]
أنت